Craig what do you think makes the
dagestani fighter so good like from this
small region of the world so much
dominance has come
I mean obviously the amount of Freestyle
Wrestling champions from that region
before he puts their wrestling above and
beyond the best uh middle of MMA and
obviously a lot of even in the Olympics
a lot of Champions out of there right so
I think that skill set combines with
them adding effective pin controls on
the ground and Jiu Jitsu submissions but
I mean again I think it's that hard
training those guys like Habib would
maintain that pressure throughout the
entire flying break guys down their
ability to fatigue us to a breaking
point I think it's something they do
best but I wonder what what that is was
that technique what is that what is it
about their upbringing because it's that
just that part of the world over the
city of Brothers with for the other
Freestyle Wrestling side to all the
Mixed Martial Arts people like it must
be part of the
the culture also they must be doing
something
I don't think I've never I haven't seen
a convincing explanation of why yet
of what's specific about their training
what's specific about their culture that
creates that